[Música]
[Aplausos]
yo no quería ser profe luego confieso
que la presentación ha estado genial
césar pero yo de pequeño lo que quería
era ser arqueólogo me encantaban los
dinosaurios me encantaba indiana jones
supongo que como muchos de vosotros a lo
mejor quería ser astronauta o científica
o futbolista el futbolista sigue de moda
os lo digo de verdad hoy tú preguntas a
los niños y siempre hay uno que te dice
profe yo de mayor quiero ser youtube y
quiero tener muchos followers
y dices bueno vale
recuerdo uno que me dijo profe yo de
mayor quiero ser robot y cesc para para
aves el que profe el robot está
conectado con google google lo sabe todo
y entonces yo sería más listo de la
clase
y dices oye pues no no está mal el
pensamiento supongo que como muchos de
vosotros estos sueños van cambiando y a
mí también me sucedió cuando me dieron
esa lista donde teníamos que apuntar las
diez carreras que uno quiere hacer
después del selectivo
ahí me invitaron al día de la familia en
el colegio de mi hermano era un colegio
de educación especial él llevaba poco
tiempo ahí
para que os voy a engañar no tenía yo
muchas ganas de ir pero al final acabe
por acompañar a mi familia que está por
ahí sentada entonces
cuando llegué vi algo que dije
wow vi a mi hermano como estaba súper
orgulloso de enseñarnos todas las cosas
que él había aprendido como esos
profesores habían logrado que mejoraran
su capacidad de comunicación su
capacidad para valerse por sí mismo su
autonomía personal y en ese momento yo
dije fuera todo yo quiero ser maestro
quiero ser como esas personas
quiero cambiar la vida de las personas
del mañana
y al final es que cambie fui yo que me
dice profe
ahora la que está cambiando en la
educación lo estamos viendo en estas
charlas vosotros los que tenéis hijos lo
veis les ponemos pizarras digitales
tablets robótica
pero toda esta tecnología también está
cambiando las personas
leí hace poco un artículo que decía que
los adultos ya no aguantan más de 10
minutos atentos
por culpa de los anuncios de la
televisión y a los niños también les
sucede los niños están cinco minutos
atentos en clase y luego anuncios
yo no sé a vosotros pero a mí me pasa
eso que dicen eres el mejor del tercer
mejor profe de españa mentira
nos pasa a todos dicen no tenemos que
trabajar el pensamiento porque memorizar
a ver google ya lo sabe todo lo decía mi
niño robot y es cierto pero claro y
cuando tienes un niño que te llega y te
dice
profe qué pasó
que no que no me interesa que me da
igual
no quiero aprender claro todos los
profes sabéis y sabemos que sin
motivación no hay aprendizaje
necesitamos motivar a los niños y
resulta que para motivar a los niños
teníamos una solución que los colegios
no estábamos aplicando no nos habíamos
dado cuenta esa solución estaba en la
logse en la al 11 en la loce en la loe
da igual que cambien las leyes
educativas está en todas se llama
comunidad educativa
y para los que no lo sabéis una
comunidad educativa está formada por
profeso por alumnos esto es lógico
y por familias
y qué es lo que hacemos que hacemos los
colegios porque a lo mejor algún profe
hay algún profe seguro bien dirán
si en mi cole ya lo hacemos llamamos
para unas tutorías en navidad oye si
mira venga a ver como canta villancico
de navidad al final del curso la
graduación igual mañana para ver el acto
del 9 de octubre fantástico
pero eso es una comunidad educativa
ya os digo yo que no una comunidad
educativa consiste en a las
familias cogerlos a vosotros y meteros
aquí en clase durante el horario lectivo
mientras los brazos estamos dando clases
para que trabajemos juntos igual alguno
me dice es para me estás diciendo que yo
vaya al cole para hacer de profe no no
te estoy diciendo que vengas al cole
para hacerte profe te estoy diciendo que
vengas al colegio para acompañar a tus
hijos
para hacer que se sientan orgullosos
igual que mi hermano estaba orgulloso de
lo que él hacía para que veáis y
compartáis con ellos para que profes y
alumnos y familias trabajemos todos
juntos eso es una comunidad educativa os
voy a dar tres ejemplos que si no me
enrollo y hay tiempo
el primero taller de matemáticas todas
las semanas lo llevo haciendo siete años
todas las semanas las familias pueden
venir a clase que lo que hacemos
trabajamos las mates porque porque
siguen siendo la asignatura más difícil
que hay en el colegio como lo hacemos
pues de una manera muy sencilla retos
matemáticos que activan la mente
trabajamos matemáticas manipulativas con
botellas con cerillas porque lo que toco
lo puedo comprender mejor pero además
ponemos problemas de matemáticas y es
genial cuando tienes ahí cinco niños
intentando resolver un problema y ves a
un papá que dice chicos yo haría una
multiplicación llega al final de la
clase cada equipo va saliendo a explicar
lo que hacen sale uno lo hemos resuelto
con una multiplicación diversa de papas
y de repente sale otro tipo y dice
nosotros hemos hecho varias sumas y nos
ha dado el mismo resultado entonces ves
cómo empiezan a cambiar las caras
y sale otro tipo te dice no hemos hecho
ninguna operación hemos usado en las
regletas hemos hecho unas gráficas y
hemos llegado al mismo resultado y
entonces es cuando el papá dice eso se
vale
pues claro ahí es cuando ellos han
aprendido ahí es cuando las familias
comprenden que hay una forma diferente
de poder enseñar venga un segundo
ejemplo
las familias sois expertas en un montón
de cosas
sabéis muchísimo más de algunas cosas
que los profes y os tenemos que hacer
para compartir ese conocimiento por
ejemplo cuando yo tengo que explicar los
metros el kilómetro el hectómetro pues
tengo un papá que es topógrafo es
impresionante cuando con herramientas de
topografía medimos el patio del colegio
los niños esos se les quiera igual
alguno me está diciendo oye oye
mira yo tengo un horario laboral yo no
puedo decirle al jefe que mañana me voy
al cole de mi hijo es lógico pero hay
soluciones puedes grabar un vídeo en tu
casa
el fin de semana graba un vídeo
cuéntanos eso y luego en clase sale tu
hija lo explica proyectamos tu vídeo
y hemos resuelto el problema de la
incompatibilidad de horario
venga la última organizar una abuela da
los abuelos también forman parte de la
familia organicemos abuela das en los
colegios es maravilloso cuando estás a
los abuelos y entonces ellos el de
cuentan a los niños cómo era su pueblo
hace 50 años está en fotos de está en
artículos antiguos
luego los niños aprenden como su pueblo
ahora les volvemos a invitar son los
niños los que se lo cuentan a los
abuelos y si los relacionamos con el
alzheimer y hacemos un documental
estamos haciendo un trabajo social
increíble
veo algunas caras que dicen bueno y
entonces esto porque no estallan todos
los colegios porque no se hacen todos
los colegios
porque hacer cosas diferentes cuesta
porque hacer cosas diferentes puestas
salir de lo que hemos hecho toda la vida
no es fácil y yo entiendo que para una
familia para un papá para una mamá para
un abuelos plantarse delante de 25 o 26
niños a tener que explicar algo dice
cada casa cada casa yo qué voy a hacer
ahí pero es que no estáis solos los
procesó estamos con vosotros yo os voy a
acompañar hoy voy a ayudar como poder
explicarlo como poder hacer que los
niños lo entiendan y el miedo desaparece
pero no son las únicas personas que
tienen miedo hay otros individuos que
vivimos entre cuatro paredes en esa zona
de confort de seguridad la llamamos
clase y a veces tenemos miedo hay
profesores que tienen miedo de dejar que
la familia sienten porque y si me juzgan
y si no me entienden
y si no me acompañan
pero el miedo no les está dejando ver
que cuando las familias las metemos
dentro de la clase
entonces se acaba esa queja de es que yo
soy profe y las familias no me entienden
no nos apoyan
se acaba porque trabajamos juntos y si
trabajamos juntos nos apoyamos
y estamos creando auténticas comunidades
de aprendizaje
auténticas comunidades de aprendizaje
además
esos profes tampoco se dan cuenta de que
los niños sienten se emocionan y estamos
vinculando emocionalmente con la memoria
a largo plazo y esos niños no lo van a
olvidar jamás lo que han hecho cuando
estaba ahí el papá la mamá el abuelo en
clase
y además ese momento en el que vosotros
tenéis el poder que os corresponde como
familias
porque hay que empoderar vos y yo te
estoy invitando pues estoy invitando a
que en clase a que vengáis a que nos
acompañéis en el colegio porque es
necesario porque una experiencia así me
hizo a mí darme cuenta de mi vocación de
que yo soy profe y ahora ahora mismo en
primaria está la presidenta de españa
del año 2060 y no hará falta repetir
elecciones está ahora
y necesita que vosotros vengáis a clase
para que en un momento ella diga yo
quiero ser
muchísimas gracias y bienvenidos a la
clase más
[Aplausos]